it's 06 22 we've been up since half five
well actually I was awake since
qualifier this morning thinking about
this action we have to take don't want
to go on strike can't afford to go on
strike but then I can't afford not to
take strike action this government has
put us in this predicament the next time
I'll talk to you i'll be at work with
the colleagues and we'll be going
walking out on strike here's the
colleagues from all the different unions
unze strike you've got unite the Royal
College of Midwives and you listen
standing together when I had three
quarters of an hour in the picket
starting to drive and it's got a big
column as well we're having lots of
support from your cars are passing their
beefiness as well though what vicks on
our side
it will try and see show you the support
that we get you from the public by the
car hey ten o'clock and they've marched
just around the whole of the QE site
and a clock still are still all the
supporters that we've had excellent
fantastic turnout fantastic turner great
field solidarity that we have with a
different unions and one of the month fo
proud of and that's the raw College of
Midwives I mean yes tonight and it's
fantastic to see them we've got Society
of radiographers couldn't do that time
but you can now baby we had our own day
absolutely and you know what in
solidarity I'll be with you until 12
o'clock